we can't do this render challenge on our
own and so we have armed ourselves with
some interns is this like a ratatouille
situation where you're piloting me we're
gonna basically take a 3d scan
self-portrait type deal and then do a
simulation with that 3d model don't let
up just okay no you're good you're good
perfect perfect i don't even know what
i'm doing george you don't even know how
to phrase that no i'm not i'm not
feeling too good about this mike i need
you to hit control us just drink okay
okay you okay
welcome back to today's render challenge
now jordan and i were supposed to be
rendering against each other today but
there's been a complication you see
today is the day of our weekly buddy
breakfast and we were doing what we call
the passage of the bacon where both of
us use both our hands to guide the bacon
into the cold oil it's just a fun thing
we do to bond spiritually and mentally
done it hundreds of times without ever
having an issue but this time ren
preheated the oil and the oil was very
hot
[Applause]
and hot hurts
hot does hurt and now we can't do this
render challenge on our own we can't hit
the keys we can't clack the mouse
so we need some new hands and so we have
armed ourselves with some interns who
have hands as well and these interns are
going to actually help us by pressing
all the buttons that we want to press
but physically can't we will use our
brains to create art but not our bodies
[Applause]
[Music]
so we've got matt here matt right mark
mark sorry mark we got mark here he's
our intern well this is my intern brett
what's up a ray of sunshine turned into
a person so are we supposed to know how
to do this you don't have to know how to
do any of this you are going to be my
hands and my fingers and you will
orchestrate everything that i want to
make happen is this like a ratatouille
situation where you're piloting me yeah
yeah and it's really just about
following me
follow me okay
okay all right this is just like mr
maggie it's more the same hand i was
kind of envisioning okay
that we could almost link in this way
that you are an extension now my fingers
what do i want to do
exactly yep yep our primary objective
today is speed we got to get these
renders done we can't get hung up on any
settings or any sort of procedures here
you do have a notebook to take notes if
you need them but i will be able to tell
you which buttons to press which
commands to type in what settings to put
and we will create a really awesome
render so that jordan and i can present
our artwork to niko to judge
originally the whole plan for the
challenge was that we're gonna basically
take a 3d scan self-portrait type deal
and then do a simulation with that 3d
model but i can't do a scan
so you're going to have to do the scan
how
we will 3d scan your head and by we i
mean brett will scan your head
i thought we were competing why wouldn't
i just sabotage him by getting a really
scan we have morals here at corridor and
we will be good sports about this and
you will both make good scans of each
other
without intentionally sabotaging it
right we'll we'll shake on it
do you want me to just have to shout i
will go back on my handshake in a moment
in a second
what's he saying we need to focus on us
right now but listen i've never met this
guy before i just don't trust him well
he's scanning my face yeah so
is there like a bonus for you if you
want this
if you come in on that i'll make sure he
loses
i'll make sure
my morals are high i'm just saying i
don't know i don't hear them whisper the
noise change who we are i agree okay all
right people don't care just open a box
put that in there and put that in your
back pocket we'll think about it later
say a prayer real quick yeah i'm with
you dear only father god thank you for
the day lord remember the crew cuts
episode we did about you scanning i
remember watching it on corridor
digital.com where people can see cool
cuts we're just going to do that again
but instead of a donkey it's brett and
your name we pray amen
we're going to go upstairs to the
kitchen to actually do the scans because
of all of our dramatic lighting will
interfere for these 3d scans we'll be
using our phones and one of my favorite
apps polycam hit done
done
so it's uploading right now okay let's
go ahead and get the other scan going
did you remember the face you practiced
okay i need to just hold i need to just
hold that that width
i don't know that works my champion oh
my champion bring it in that's the first
victory of the day i just held my mouth
it's uploading
we are here ready to go on this
challenge we have an hour and a half
before our first break and then we'll
have a little bit of time after that to
finish everything up we're gonna have to
move
extra fast
for honor let's shake on it let's do it
a little further away
phase one
you can spend
okay uh all right
okay this is it this is it mark okay oh
no our battery's running on low oh
should we are we plugged in already off
to a bad start okay so what i was
thinking for what we could do here we
could do a simulation of your head
crumbling to meaty bits
of my
head let's explore this okay let's do
this the first thing is the viewport
here and this is where everything is
going to exist that you will see we'll
have to chop off your shoulders so it's
just from the neck up but then we'll
have to close that hole and then we will
then run that through a voronoi fracture
and then apply a second material to the
inside
that mesh under the mesh tower obj click
on that and start the download you
should see that populate oh i think we
got it sweet excellent work so far okay
we're making progress so great the
basics this is rumbling
i don't know why you're taking notes on
this how am i supposed to remember you
said so much he said about a vernacular
pressure is it meaty bits
mark
i think you might be thinking a little
too much here
here let's uh i need you to put your
hand on the mouse instead of the pin
you got this you got this
oh my gosh dude excellent that's perfect
thank you jordan thank you you're a
natural thank you man we're moving so
quick
and boom
right there not too bad
the eyes are too bad the eyes you know i
think we can work with it i think we can
work with it this is gonna be great and
start downloading start download now
open up cinema 4d okay click on the cube
in the viewport yeah awesome click on
the object tab awesome and set the size
to
five awesome job that's perfect
excellent work this is gonna be the base
of our statue right
now ctrl s for me save and always save
your work all right what do i do next uh
go ahead and zoom out we're basically
going to cut off your shoulders we don't
need them okay all right once we
actually delete your shoulders we're
going to optimize the mesh of your head
go down to smoothing about halfway down
the list now don't let up just okay no
you're good you're good perfect perfect
this is great
this is great oh my goodness that's some
hostile that's okay it's okay
now what we want to do is we want to
bevel the edges all that means is
nothing in the world has a hard edge
even this table see it's like a rounded
edge so we want to give a rounded edge
to this just it looks so much nicer yeah
like yeah like that perfect let go oh my
gosh she's beveling edges already this
is amazing
let's go ahead and add a ground plane
hold that down and i'll open up a menu
shift
don't have to hold shift no shift go to
the
plane yes
now you've made a ground plane
boom look at that dude that's pretty
good it does yeah
i said it was pretty good
it does it's not a proper response
you're right yeah
[Music]
yeah click on water break let me give
you there yeah
let me know when you know when you good
i hear you yes i'm trying to tell you
sorry son that's okay we'll get better
so the next thing we need to do
is break your head
are you ready to do this
we're going to do the vortigaunt
fracture for your head
okay
we've got our base
now we're going to make our
psych brett do you know what a psych is
uh
a psyche yes someone who can uh read the
future and like tell your yes i know
dean of course it's like that but it's
not that at all it is basically just
this
it's the ramp background click on that
and then click on light psych fantastic
we've got our psych
oh god our strike baby so you guys are
coming up on one hour left how you guys
feeling
great
great
it's not going good
you know usually when i'm working on
things i'm working by myself you know i
i i'm in control of everything i have
everything
in hand and it's my idea being put
forward so
going into this and knowing that i was
going to just be a vehicle for someone
else to execute their idea you know it's
not something i'm used to
do i get any say in the creative process
do you want to say
i was thinking we could do some kind of
like
distant landscape where you had this guy
who was like holding on to this tree
over here and he was on this like
hillside and then you see me all huge in
the distance like but my but there's
like a lot it's like i'm i'm a giant
that died on a volcano right so you see
me and i'm here with my hair this is
hair but then out of my eyes just lava
goes
out of it and then but this is like
super in the distance and you see like
shooting stars at night so the lava like
illuminates the rest of it and you got
like this guy i don't know he's got like
a sword or something
i regret asking for your input all right
let's move on
enter in emitter e-m-i-t-t-e-r
hit enter we've got an emitter all right
so we've got this this is great hit play
for me we should see some some balls
coming out this is exactly what we want
fantastic now what we want to do is we
want to add dynamics to this what we
should see is the balls coming out and
falling to the ground and landing on the
ground
beautiful my man look at this speed
so this is already looking fantastic so
the next thing we need to do is we need
to basically tell the program that the
plane that you've made and that the head
that you fractured are both physics
objects so it'll land on the plane yes
so there's going to be two different
physics objects we're going to add um i
just realized we've been going for
almost an hour and we haven't even saved
the project yet it's still called
untitled so hit control s he hadn't
saved the whole time
that's really bold like he's fine lately
mike i need you to hit control us just
drink okay okay
[Applause]
how you guys feeling oh man feeling good
so far we're moving like lightning right
now it totally did revive really yeah
between the teams this is this seems
like the laid-back casualty yeah this is
we have a zen philosophy here where you
can't really learn if you're panicking
and it's all about brotherhood and
bonding and you know sharing information
it's supposed to be a beautiful thing
you know what let's take a break for a
minute let's do some meditation jordan
i don't want a couple directly apart
from you
vision a perfect render
the pride
the smile on my face
the warmth of my embrace
what's up mark hey it's really stressful
over with ryan well over here is love my
friend this is all love look look at the
smile the sun is coming out thank you
everyone's smiling
i haven't smiled at all i don't think
i've ever smiled welcome to our side of
this this is beautiful wow this is
beautiful but we are still competing so
maybe it's best if we just that's true
you know you owe me a okay
i think you stopped holding my hand mark
but honestly you've made it weird
so if you can
ah
all right well let me know when you do
this again oh yeah yeah
yeah right there for sure we'll send an
email
you guys gonna keep going uh no we're
probably gonna be out of here but then
we're pretty much done we just gotta
clear something we're gonna wrap up
clear some negatives put the chairs away
clear the negative energy a little dump
so
but we'll see you
okay
in for four out for eight
mark and i playing around with those
simulations reminded me of an audiobook
that i really liked called off to be the
wizard thanks to today's sponsor audible
i'm gonna tell you about it it's
actually a very fun series it's
light-hearted it's also very nerdy
because it basically deals with this
dude who figures out that he's living in
a simulation by discovering a text
document and when he edited his height
in that text document he became taller
when he discovers that he can literally
edit reality around him he kind of
becomes a god and gets a little out of
hand until he gets in trouble and so he
ends up retreating to the middle ages
because he can travel through time and
space and discovers that there's a whole
community of other wizards there and
that's where the book kind of goes from
there there are several titles in this
series at this point and i've listened
to all of them on audible what are some
of the benefits of audible well let me
tell you the premium plus membership is
excellent you get a free title every
single month included in your membership
on top of all of the audible originals
that they've got they have a whole
breadth of titles and audiobooks and
theatricals you know like high
production podcasts they got tons of
those they've got lots of comedy shows
they've got like these guided wellness
things if you want to like do some
meditation with your membership you can
choose one title per month to own and
it's literally yours forever and the app
itself makes it very easy to listen to
audible pretty much anywhere you can
download the titles or stream them my
favorite feature is to be able to
literally tell my amazon echo to like
pick up reading the audiobook after i
get home from driving without any break
in the audiobook like it's able to pick
it up exactly where i left off if that
sounds at all interesting to you head on
over to audible.com corridor crew or you
can use your phone and you can text core
or crew to 500 500 and you'll
automatically get that membership and
that free trial but for now let's get
back to trying to get mark to make
anything
progress is going a little slower than i
initially anticipated no no no focus
focus
i need mark to trust the process and
i think he's getting too inside his head
he's trying to take too many notes see
mark came to corridor to learn visual
effects and i am here to win
so for both of us to actually achieve
these goals he needs to clear his head
and i need to be better at communicating
i think if we both focus on these things
we will achieve our goal of learning
visual effects and winning
let's chat real quick here uh don't
worry about this nick let's just uh come
with me come with me come with me
on aren't we on a time crisis yeah we
are we are this is important though
come here
you're doing great but i think you're
getting into your head too much a little
bit i'm not in my head i'm trying to
channel your head through my head but
your head's not fitting because your
head's too big and my head is huge you
see my head yeah it's massive yeah what
are they doing
they're wasting time to me they're all
over the place what are they talking
about dean i need you to trust the
creative process here and so for that we
need to have a unified idea and i think
what we have is a pretty good one of
your head fracturing to pieces because
that's something that i know that you
can do in the next hour
but in order for that to happen i need
you
to be my arms will you be
my arms today
i'm just not used to giving up control
you know i've been doing youtube on my
own for a very long time so it's very
hard for me to assume that other people
actually know better than me
i will
trust you thank you i will empty my mind
okay i will become a vessel
now i want to try to
animate the head we can do this we can
totally do this you're a very good
student we want it to end at the base of
his neck okay so a little lower right
there are you teaching brent to rig
right now we're rigging baby this guy is
a natural we're gonna rig this head uh
and hit play let's just see what that
looks like
oh yeah buddy
really good okay how are you feeling i
need to empty my mind
ready
okay now that your head is clear we're
going to turn both the fractured head
and the ground plane into physics
objects so that they can actually be
simulated if everything went according
to plan hit the space bar and it should
collapse
[Music]
but i'm dead
i've literally never done a physician
before feels cool right okay brett so
the head rig should be working with the
emitter now why don't you hit play on
that
my guy
oh my gosh this is strange it's strange
but it's working and that's really what
all we're aiming for right now do you
feel the energy i feel the energy from
you teaching me son there's nothing
about these sleeves that are magical
it's you oh my gosh stop let's do this
you can keep going though you can say
that a couple more times no man
[Music]
i'm getting too distracted clear your
head
i need to make more space for my head
what's happening is my brain is so
powerful and strong it's actually
pushing back through the connection into
your head so you're getting some of my
adhd [ __ ] dude i also have adhd this
is no wonder we keep getting so
distracted
that's fine now we're getting caught in
the weekend about 25 minutes left 25
minutes okay awesome yeah we're feeling
all right feeling all right are we can
we legally donate any time to them
because we're really starting to
sympathize you know what i mean
uh our hands are tied
so we are going to take this up a level
now i think you need to be hit in the
head with a wrecking ball okay how do
you feel about it i'm okay with that
right click on your sphere
rigid body perfect and what we're going
to do is we're going to give it some
initial velocity so at the beginning of
the shot it'll shoot out like a
projectile okay okay that is going the
correct direction now let's up that even
more
i'm dead that was actually pretty cool
that's pretty cool
now i want to do the camera i'm going to
like get a nice cool dynamic looping
camera move that should be pretty
satisfying play that for me
we should start zoomed in
and then we push back in it's not the
most beautiful move in the world but we
got something done that's what we're
going for that's uh that's something
it's something yeah yeah that look it
looks pretty good to me
i think that looks pretty good so to
take this a little bit further we need
something to come clear all of your head
debris away
um
that could be
a box it could be a rolling pin it could
be your head again
i think my head again would probably be
the best option all right all right okay
the idea here is that we're going to
have your head kind of like slide in the
frame to push all the debris out
and it'll come back rotate up and shrink
back into place we're gonna have to
scale it up okay click and drag the
scale
and go until it's at like yeah there you
go perfect that big
yeah okay
great great okay great uh so now it
doesn't sound great you guys now have a
10-minute warning your models and your
animations need to be placed before this
phase ends
plug the orange sun
orange sun or sun into the texture oh my
that's the beautiful orange
so pointy
i mean it's more like a nubby gesture it
comes comes on the frame pushes stuff
off and then returns to the center where
it was
yeah sweet we have an animation we are
just going to drag and drop some
materials here we're adding a metallic
material to the ball and then we can add
a couple other random materials to the
ground in the back five minute morning
uh
five minute warning team
models and animations need to be locked
phase two is only lighting and
finalizing okay go go control d uh ctrl
d
and then uh put click bake so that's
locking in the simulation so it's not
gonna like openly simply final minute in
this phase one more phase to go
perfect perfect okay now let's call this
locked the animation is done hit ctrl s
oh and that's time hands off save your
projects we're moving in and off
save your projects we are moving into
the next phase we know teaching is
exhausting we've scheduled this
10-minute break before we start the next
phase which is a 30-minute
your renders
finalize your lighting and get it done
in the last phase so
i need a snack
i'm gonna go uh make something real
quick um when i get back i'll walk you
through the final stages of this the
physics is baked it moves it all out of
the way it's lined up the lighting isn't
perfect but it's okay
i think that
we're very close to something being done
i heard that mark was writing notes and
stuff trying to get a better feel of
everything i didn't really have time
like there's just so much happening so
the only note that i really have is just
uh listen to jordan
i mean you know i'm listening i'm
interpreting but it's like the things
are going by so quickly you know like
the tools and stuff so it's like i can
basically follow uh what jordan has but
it's it's gone the moment i've done it
wait is picking snack then yeah well
we're about to yeah yeah okay we could
cook me an extra slice
okay
no worries at all see that means less
bacon for us i know that but you know we
got to work what we got we're taking our
snack break our mid-render snack break
yeah which is actually a old corridor
tradition yeah we've been doing it for
years i mean i love snack time because
it's a chance to refuel to rehydrate on
some bacon grease and just get back in
the game
one two three
[Applause]
during
the mentor break
injured hands at all
jordan and ren wanted to try to cook up
some more bacon for some reason they are
no longer going to have their eyesight
for the rest of this challenge you guys
are going to have to take art direction
from the rest and make them just be a
verbal encyclopedia oh i don't know what
happened i don't know why they were
cooking bacon but they're going to this
next place blind
so so sorry
that seems like a hospital that doesn't
seem like we should continue this
challenge
brett you can do this man
mark
why were you cooking bacon i couldn't
help it man it's a compulsion i needed
the bacon the show must go on though
mark we must finish this render okay
okay so brett here jordan i got you son
i got you son i got you thank you
brother be careful be careful be careful
be careful so
it is up to you
to do the rest of all of this i need you
to have creative control over the rest
of this project on your own i will do my
best to help
but i will be unable to actually see
what it is you're doing you have grown
so much
and i think this baby bird is ready to
fly
all right i think so yes 30 minute timer
to hit the render button begins now use
your mentor to the fullest of their
capabilities but it's on younow
have you heard of three-point lighting
yeah fantastic i think that's what we go
for here but i think maybe we do three
area lights huh maybe we do three area
lights okay and you just you angle them
where you feel they should be
so we've added an hdri that works as a
pretty good like bass line for what we
want to have for the lights so now we
need to add some lights to our scene
we're gonna want to basically have a big
edge light so we can see the contour
details behind the back of your head i'm
thinking frame left here and the a
little bit of fill this is like kind of
the spice layer where we really like
zazz up the the render
sensing that you're doing great uh
i don't really have much
faith in what i'm doing right now jordan
i think that this is kind of a message
looking like a zombie like the
lighting's making me look like a zombie
that's that's so hot right now i've
created a 300 by 300 light directly
behind my head that is shining at an
extreme intensity 300 by 300 i made it
bigger let's make it smaller no
all right i'll make it smaller
made it smaller
do you have your first slide in position
no i kind of
trying to figure out where i
kind of lost i keep moving the camera on
accident um
the area light is changing the colors of
the whole image i just delete the whole
thing
[Music]
and don't forget you have the undo at
your disposal i wish i could see well
you can't you made bacon and you burnt
your eyes out was it worth it
of course it was worth it did you even
horse did you eat the bacon i will
i'm envisioning what he's doing and i'm
absolutely loving it
i couldn't be prouder
i'm not i'm not feeling too good about
this like jordan's been able to like
look at the screen and then sort of
navigate me but now um this is not going
to be good brett
one thing that i've been very proud of
in working with you is how good of a
listener you've been
what i'm needing now though yes is for
you to
use the mouth
for sure i think the biggest thing for
me is figuring out what i'm doing
um
to figure out what to how how to open my
mouth you know like i don't even know
what i'm doing you don't even know how
to phrase the questions when you were
here without this this on your face yes
life was a lot easier
tell me about life is a little darker
now oh
and that's why you bring in the light
i think we're very close to hitting
rendering right dc motion blur i do
hell yeah dude hell yeah dude
what kind of feel we going for we're
going for darker i mean this is this is
your baby now you know i want you to
light it the way you want to light it
but we can certainly go brighter so yeah
and over on the right uh go ahead and
click the little uh folder button two
minutes left two minutes
mr blindfold just two minutes we'd like
you to get the render button by then the
render button
darn it how do you feel about how it
looks
um it looks very plain you know what i
mean it looks very plain which is fine
nothing too dynamic no we don't need
that you know maybe we just put a pause
in the lighting like delete whatever you
don't like let's get it to where it's
like passable for you okay now put in
where it says kilobytes put in five zero
zero zero zero
where where click the enable we want to
enable that
from zero okay
got it okay is it on now okay okay
control s uh
hit shift r
click run button
is it rendering is it i don't know
that's it you got it that's it did
something pop up something popped up rgb
updated updating one
oh my god
dude brother we did it
nice
how do you feel a fist bump
nice dude there's enough lights there is
enough light in there okay is there like
dramatic shaping to the light so cause
you have the edge light and you should
be a little around the edges i got like
all the edges you don't want to have too
much light because then everything is
just too illuminated
that was the most stressful thing i've
ever done in my life dude like
i am proud of you thank you
i think
you were the best arms i could have
possibly hoped for
i hope it looks good
i try no you know what i have zero hope
that it's gonna look good
because i
know it's gonna look good because i
trust
you
i trust your creative vision here to
pull this through the end
yeah
okay so now what
now we uh do something that all visual
effects ours are incredibly familiar
with
we wait
how long
well
i think we're gonna need to wait all
night
[Music]
it's a good thing that we're able to
heal so quickly from tragic oil
accidents it's the l.a water there's
something in it ah you know what i think
you're right the renders baked all night
and now they are ready to serve up to
nico who has been requesting we give him
the coolest renders we can make look the
training corridor doesn't stop for
anybody whether or not you have hands or
you have eyeballs doesn't matter i need
my renders i need them now niko yes sir
i can unequivocally say this is the best
render i have ever done
that's i like that confidence is this
the only render you've ever done
what was the question all right i guess
uh we're up so mark i need you to click
it
wait my hands work again
oh
hello
i do like how it feels like it's in
heaven
you said you fixed the lighting we had a
whole background that we had made that
was a nice thing what happened to the
edge light that you were making you said
the edge light looked great look you
told me how to make one
i forgot
how you told me how to make another
and
i couldn't figure out how to make it any
dimmer
so i owned it
i owned it
first impressions it's got a little bit
of drama to it which is nice
then the big head comes in and sweeps it
all away and that's honestly pretty
satisfying that's a step up i wasn't
expecting the 3d scan looks good i like
the shininess like the inside of the
pieces the background being pure white
you know it gives you some nice
reflections but it's just it's a little
boring but all things considered
especially considering like
you've never touched a 3d program before
this is like a solid like i'm five weeks
into my 3d program experience
mark and i we started off a little slow
i think he was taking everything i said
a little too seriously however that
generated this
situation where you were actually
learning very quickly and it gave me the
confidence to trust you
in your artistic vision so i wasn't even
worried during that last bit when i lost
my eyes because i knew that you were
gonna make something very cool because
you convinced me that you could in all
honesty you are
quite a good teacher i did take in
everything that you did say or as much
of it as i could fit in my head the bar
right now is pretty high this is like a
very clean render it looks really pretty
materials are great
motion blur is like spot on like it
looks really good i i hope what jordan
and brett have done
is just as tasty
we'll find out soon
so
all right jordan and i'll go ahead and
press that button i believe in you chan
i don't know what we're going to see
here
on you guys
whoa
there's animation in it wow wow you lit
this person
you know lighting-wise i'm very proud of
you brad i really am because i know i
know you are panicked i know you're a
worried champ once the blindfolds came
on that's when um
i lost everything and i thought at one
point i um
deleted everything i thought i was
pretty screwed
because jordan couldn't see anything but
the fact that you went simple you went
with a simple hdri to carry the scene
and just let it be what it needs to be
the fact that you committed to that last
second i really respect you for that
thank you son the decision to put a
little stand below brett's 3d model so
that it's anchored to the space as if
it's a sculpture
which lends to the creepiness of the
sculpture than moving and vomiting
i'm so proud of you buddy thank you come
here i'm so proud to see one of those
hugs come here
no i'm going right that was good all
right okay honestly yeah i feel like you
deserve to i feel like we can bring in
the fall time
love you too champ no i didn't i didn't
say that well
so i know these videos are lame when you
don't pick a winner but in all honesty
these are both really good they both
demonstrate the true goal of this which
is to have you guys
step into the shoes of a cg artist and
try making a render so all in all like
they're both really good
i don't think i can pick a winner all i
think i can do is judge them and i judge
them as
adequate
thank you
pick a winner coward
declare someone better i know how i'll
determine the winner
what does hdr stand for
i dynamic range
[Music]
yes we win
yeah
you did it
what do i win
ah just you know the love admiration of
all
eternal respect
the tools that are available to do
these seemingly mystical incredible
things are
so much more accessible than people
understand like cinema 4d as far as i
know is a paid program but there's free
alternatives out there that do pretty
much the same thing when taking the tech
you have on your phone to do a 3d scan
to generate a 3d model which i don't
believe was an option even a few years
ago probably and you're able to just pop
it in
place all of these different textures on
it you're able to animate it you're able
to have these simulations physical
simulations i remember watching tech
demos of simulations like 10 years ago
and i never imagined that it would be
possible to even have
that capability in
my home i've never touched the software
before in my life but now i realize like
oh my god i can make whatever i want
so long as i put the effort in this was
a lot of fun and i feel like even i
learned a whole lot from this experience
so i think we should try doing this
challenge again leave a comment down
below suggesting who should be the shmo
and who should be the pro and maybe
we'll do another one soon subscribe
thanks for watching
snack time
[Music]
underneath